ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WE
HAVE IN THIS SPECIAL MEETING.
ONE BILL TO HEAR AND THAT IS AB
EIGHT THIRTY TWO. MISTER CHOOSE
BILL WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. RESEARCH PEOPLE.
HI WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WE DO NOT
YET HAVE A QUORUM. SO WE WILL
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE
ONE BUILT HERE TODAY AT EIGHT
THIRTY TWO BY MR CHIU. SO ALL
THE TO BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OKAY I'M SORRY I. THE
ME LET ME DO THE PROCEDURAL
STUFF THAT. WE'RE OBLIGATED TO
DO WE ARE STILL OBVIOUSLY
OPERATING WITH SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND UTILIZING
DIFFERENT PROTOCOLS BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC WHICH IS
CONTINUING. WE DO HAVE SOME
ROOM IN THE HEARING ROOM BUT
YET WE'RE STILL PRACTICING
SOCIAL DISTANCING TO SOME
EXTENT THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL
AND IN THE HEARING ROOM MASKS
ARE STILL REQUIRED TO ENSURE
SAFETY FOR EVERYONE. WITNESSES
CAN PARTICIPATE TODAY BY COMING
TO THE HEARING ROOM IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO RAISE
YOUR HANDS AND WE DO HAVE A
MICROPHONE HERE WE DO ASK THAT
NO ONE TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
AND WE HAVE A SEPARATE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION OUTSIDE.
WHERE PEOPLE CAN TESTIFY AND WE
WILL ALSO BE TAKING. TELEPHONE
COMMENTS AT WHEN THAT TIME
COMES IN. THE TOLL FREE NUMBER
TO CALL IN TO COMMENT ON ABA
THIRTY TWO IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN THAT IS
877-692-8957 THAT NUMBER SHOULD
BE ON YOUR SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING ON A COMPUTER. IT IS
ALSO AVAILABLE IN THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO- OH
TWO. THAT IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO- TO. SO WITH THAT OUT
OF THE WAY. I THINK WE DO HAVE
A QUORUM SO LET'S ESTABLISH
SUPPORT. STONE HERE GALLAGHER
HERE CHAU CHEUK HERE DAVIES
HERE GONZALEZ. HOLDEN KALRA
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
CORRECT ALRIGHT MR TOO AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. COLLEAGUES AB THIRTY
TWO ADDRESSES AND EVICTION
CRISIS THAT LOOMS OF CURRENT
PROTECTIONS ARE NOT EXTENDED
BEYOND JUNE THIRTIETH WHICH IS
THIS WEDNESDAY. DESPITE
VACCINATIONS IN THE ECONOMY RE
OPENING MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE
STILL AND PRECARIOUS FINANCIAL
SITUATIONS. TENANTS STRUGGLING
WITH SKYROCKETING RENTS BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC HAVE BORNE THE
BRUNT OF UNPRECEDENTED JOB
LOSSES DURING THE PAST FIFTEEN
MONTHS. THIS PAST MONTH ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSEHOLDS
REPORTED TO THE CENSUS SLIGHT
OR NO CONFIDENCE IN THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY NEXT MONTH'S
RENT. A RECENT POLICY LIKE
ANALYSIS ESTIMATED NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS
ARE BEHIND ON RENT. AND AT THE
SAME TIME CALIFORNIA'S RECEIVED
A RECORD FIVE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL RENTAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDS BUT AS WE ALL
KNOW ONLY A SMALL FRACTION IS
ACTUALLY BEEN RECEIVED BY
STRUGGLING RENTERS AND
LANDLORDS. WITH THE BILL
FUNDING AND TEAM ENDING
ELECTION PROTECTIONS NOW WOULD
BE FUMBLING ON THE ONE YARD
LINE. IT WOULD BE TRAGIC TO
PICK FAMILIES ON TO THE STREET
IF WE CAN KEEP THEM IN THEIR
HOMES WITH RENT REALLY FUNDING.
THIS BILL DOESN'T NUMBER OF
THINGS FIRST IT EXTENDS THE
CURRENT EVICTION PROTECTIONS
FOR THREE MORE MONTHS UNTIL
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH. SO THAT
ELIGIBLE TENANTS AND THE
LANDLORDS CAN RECEIVE FUNDING.
SECOND THIS BILL EXPANDS
PAYMENT RATES FOR LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS. CURRENTLY LANDLORDS
ARE REQUIRED TO FORGIVE 20% A
RENTAL DEBT IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE FOR THE REMAINING
80% OR ELSE THE TENANT WILL
ONLY RECEIVE ASSISTANCE 425% OF
RENTAL DEBT. THIS BILL
ELIMINATES THOSE REQUIREMENTS
SUCH THAT LANDLORDS AND TENANTS
WOULD BE ABLE TO RECEIVE A 100%
OF RENT OWED. FOR THOSE WHO
ALREADY RECEIVE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE REPLIED FOR IT. TOP
UP PAYMENTS WILL ASSIST GETTING
THEM UP TO A 100% THAT WILL BE
AUTOMATICALLY PROCESSED.
LANDLORDS WHOSE TENANTS HAVE
MOVED OUT BUT ARE STILL OWED
RENTAL PAYMENTS CAN APPLY AS
WELL. AND TENANTS WILL ALSO BE
ABLE TO APPLY FOR RENTAL
ASSISTANCE DIRECTLY. THIRD
AFTER EVICTION PROTECTIONS END
ON SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH THIS
BILL CREATES A SIX MONTH
BACKSTOPS PROCESS DEPOSIT
ACTIONS FOR TENANTS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE BUT NEED ADDITIONAL
TIME TO ACCESS AT. AND FOURTH
COURT RECORDS RELATED TO
EVICTIONS CORRECT NONPAYMENT
DURING COVERT WAR FOR THE
COLLECTION OF COVERED RENTAL
DEBT WILL BE PERMANENTLY SEALED
TO AVOID IMPACTING A PERSON'S
LONG TERM CREDIT OR ABILITY TO
APPLY. FOR FUTURE HOUSING. WHAT
PRIOR COVERT EVICTION
PROTECTION BILLS THIS BILL IS
BY NO MEANS PERFECT. BUT IF WE
DON'T MOVE THIS BILL BEFORE
JUNE THIRTIETH WE COULD SEE A
WAVE OF AFFECTIONS AND
HOMELESSNESS WELL BILLIONS OF
FEDERAL FUNDING OUR UNTAPPED WE
WOULD SERIOUSLY UNDERMINE THE
CHANCES OF HELPING OUR MOST
VALUABLE CALIFORNIANS RECOVER
FROM THE PANDEMIC. WITH THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO
OUR MAIN WITNESSES WE HAVE
BRIAN ACOSTA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. AS WELL
AS DEBT CARLTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND I ALSO WANT TO
JUST MENTION WE HAVE IN CASE OR
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ON STAND BY.
A TECHNICAL WITNESS MYLES WHITE
FROM THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY%
WITHOUT. LIKE TO TURN OVER TO
WITNESSES. THANK YOU THIS IS
YOUR YOU HAVE THOSE THREE
WITNESSES LISTED. NEVER COLTON
BRYAN ACOSTA DAN MILES WHITES
SO WE'LL START WITH THE
OVERCROWDING PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS DIFFICULTY WITH A
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A
FEW WORDS TODAY. YOU KNOW WE'RE
HERE FOR THE THIRD TIME TO
EXTEND EVICTION MORATORIUM CA
BELIEVE AND I HOPE YOU'LL AGREE
THE INDUSTRY HAVE DONE MORE
THAN ITS FAIR SHARE. FOR NEARLY
EIGHTEEN MONTHS MANY HOUSING
PROVIDERS HAVE RECEIVED LITTLE
OR NO RENT AND THE BILL GIVES
TENANTS ANOTHER THREE MONTHS
BEFORE THE REQUIRED TO PAY. ALL
THREE BILLS HAVE ALLOWED
TENANTS TO RETURN THE
DECORATION OF HARDSHIP TO THE
OWNER. NO RENT WAS DUE AND NO
PROOF OF HARDSHIP REQUIRED.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT
THAT WITH EACH EXTENSION
LEGISLATION HAVE NOT ADDRESSED
THE SITUATION WHERE A TENANT
RETURNS THE DECORATION. BUT THE
OWNER LATER LEARNS OF THE
TENANT DOES NOT QUALIFY FOR
FUNDING. THEY REFUSED TO FILL
OUT THE FUNDING APPLICATION OR
THEY'VE LEFT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT. IN THE END AND THEN
THESE THE MOST EGREGIOUS
SITUATIONS THESE TENANTS WILL
HAVE A LIVE RENT FREE FOR
NEARLY TWO YEARS. HOUSING
PROVIDERS WHO WERE UNABLE TO
EVICT THESE TENANTS WILL NEVER
RECOVER ANY RENT FROM HIS
TENANTS BECAUSE THE BILL
DOESN'T ALLOW FOR IT. AND AS
YOU MOVE FORWARD WE ASK THAT
THESE OWNERS NOT BE FORGOTTEN
WHEN THE FIRST REPORTS COME
FROM STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND THE ACCOUNT
FOR THE NUMBER OF TENDED TO
FAIL TO APPLY OR WHO WHICH WERE
REJECTED BECAUSE THEY DON'T
QUALIFY. WE AFTER THE STATE
CONSIDERED LOCKED. RENT
PAYMENTS TO THOSE HOUSING
PROVIDERS. AFTER ALL WITH LOCAL
AND STATE SYSTEMS THAT ALLOW
THESE KIND OF TOOK NOR THEIR
OBLIGATIONS TO PAY THE RENT. WE
MIGHT NOT BE HERE TODAY IF THE
MONEY HAD COME SOONER IN MANY
SITUATIONS OWNERS AND TENANTS
APPLY FOR FUNDING IN MARCH AND
STILL TODAY THEY'VE HEARD
NOTHING. ALL THAT SAID I DO
WANT TO SAY THAT WE DO HAVE
SOME VERY. GOOD AND IMPORTANT
THINGS OUT OF AB EIGHT THIRTY
TWO. WE HAVE WENT COVERED AT
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT. PREEMPTION
OF LOCAL LAWS THAT DIFFER FROM
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO. AND
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PAYMENTS TO
LANDLORDS WANT TO QUALIFIED
TENANT HAS MOVED OUT. IN
SUMMARY EIGHT THIRTY TWO ISN'T
ISN'T PERFECT. IT'S THE ONLY
OPTION HOUSING PROVIDERS AND
TENANTS HAVE TODAY WE BELIEVE
IT'S CRITICAL TO GET THIS
MEASURE TO THE GOVERNOR AND TO
EXPEDITE THE DISBURSEMENT. OF
RENTAL ASSISTANCE FUNDS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR LISTENING.
THANK YOU AND THEN. ACOSTA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU MR CHIU
PRESENTING THE BILL- BRIAN I
GOT DONE GAP OF THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION. LIKE THE PRIOR
SPEAKER- WE TO DO NOT TO BILLS
THAT'S A PERFECT BUT WE THINK
IT PROVIDES CRITICAL.
PROTECTIONS THAT MUST BE
EXTENDED- I WANT TO NOTE. THAT
HIS ANTENNAS THE DEPARTMENT
CERTIFICATION THAT THE PACE AT
WHICH WE ARE GETTING. THE
BILLIONS THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED
A FEDERAL FUNDS OUT THE DOOR TO
PEOPLE WHO NEED THOSE PAYMENTS
IT'S GOING VERY SLOWLY. THAT'S
THE LYNCHPIN OF ALL OF THIS SO
WHILE WE EXTEND THESE
PROTECTIONS THROUGH SEPTEMBER
AND WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT- WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF. THE
PROVISIONS WHICH PROVIDE
ESSENTIALLY AN OFF RAMP FOR
TENANTS WHO FIND. THEMSELVES IN
AN EVICTION ACTION. YEAH NOT
YET REACHED. ASSISTANCE FOR
WHICH ARE. ELIGIBLE THAT THOSE
ARE IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS. BUT
GIVEN THE PACE IN WHICH THOSE
DOLLARS ARE GOING OUT. I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL THAT AS WE MOVE
THIS FORWARD AND WE MUST MOVE
FORWARD AND- AND ARE HOPEFUL
THAT IT WILL REPORT TODAY IN
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IT.
PROBABLY BUT AS WE DO THAT WE
CANNOT TAKE OUR EYE OFF THIS
PROBLEM- IF THE UPTAKE IN UP.
I'M SORRY THAT PICKED DOES NOT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH TECH IN THE
RATE AT WHICH WE'RE GETTING THE
DOLLARS OUT WE'RE GOING TO BE
BACK HERE HAVING THE SAME
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT WOULD
BE. CRITICAL FLAWS ALLOW. TO
TURN BACK ON WHAT WE'VE GOT
MONEY SITTING IN THE BANK THAT
COULD. THAT COULD PROTECT THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS AND SO WITH TODAY'S
ACTION WE ARE MOVING FORWARD
WITH HER PERCENT PAYMENTS. AND
CONTINUED PROTECTION BUT WE
STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
AND WE CONTINUE TO HELP THAT
WILL BE PARTNERS. WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
IN MAKING THIS PROGRAM WORK
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND GET THE
DOLLARS TO EVERYONE. THAT IS IN
ME. THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
OUR DOMINANCE. THANK YOU AND
THEN THE THIRD WITNESS MYLES
WHITE FROM THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES IN HOUSING
AGENCY. I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
AVAILABLE FOR. QUESTIONS OR DID
YOU WANNA MAKE A COMMENT AS
WELL. THANK YOU CHAIR UMBILICAL
PROFESSION AGAINST ANYTHING
HOWEVER. THANK YOU. NOT GONNA
OPEN IT UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS.
WHEN ASKED FOR THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OR
OPPOSED WAR. DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE A POSITION TO WEIGH IN.
TOGETHER SO FIRST TASK IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO. GIVE US YOUR
POSITION ON AB EIGHT THIRTY
TWO. SEEING THAT IS THERE
ANYONE AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITES. RIGHT SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES THAT FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE THEIR POSITION
ON AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO AGAIN WE
WILL NOT BE TAKING ANY FURTHER
TESTIMONY SO WE'D APPRECIATE
GETTING YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
EITHER SUPPORT. OPPOSE OR-
NEUTRAL OR OTHERWISE ON AB.
EIGHT THIRTY TWO. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OR OTHERWISE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN
WHY NOT BEEN THERE AT THIS TIME
FOR COMMENT ON EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY TWO. WELL FIRST GOTO
LINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR TURN MEMBERS WILL BE A
SWEET SHOP ON THE OUT THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI PARKS AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA THANK YOU. AND MAXIMAL
TIMELINE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KEEP OUT OF THE HOUSE OF
THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
MAXIMAL TO LINE TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESPECTFULLY AND WITH EIGHTY
SEVEN CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE THANK YOU.
IN FACT SOME OF THE LINE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO WONDER
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
OFFERED SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. MAXIMO
TIME FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
EQUITY RUN KING STAND WE
REPRESENT- THE ELEMENTS SUCH
ISSUE ORANGE COUNTY COVERING
ALL OF ORANGE COUNTY THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CITIES OF
SOUTHERN LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION- WHICH IS
EAST BAY RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION COVERING TOO LARGE.
A BAY AREA COUNTY USED AND TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ASSOCIATIONS
COLLECTIVELY REPRESENTING ALL
OF CALIFORNIA- ALL IN
OPPOSITION. AND AS A REMINDER
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
PRESS ONE THEN THEIR OWN NOW
AND AGAIN THIS IS FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY TWO AND WE HAVE
ONE MORE IN THE CUBICLE TO LINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
GET AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TINA
RETALIATES WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY. THANK YOU
TO SHIP ON THEIR COMMITMENT TO
PRACTICE PROTECT TENANTS FROM
THE DETECTION AND- X. BREAK
CHANCE I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO-
WHAT ARE SUPPORT FOR THE 1100%
OFFERING OF A REAR TEMPLE
SECOND PRESS FOR ELIGIBLE
TENANTS. HOWEVER WE REMAIN
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL BECAUSE WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT THE OPTION
OF LOCAL LAW AND IT STILL WILL
BE VULNERABLE KIND AND I'M
PROTECTED. AN ACCURATE
DEPICTION THANK YOU. I MEAN TO
HAVE A MORE TO THE QUEUE. TO
LINE UP. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RANDY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND IT'S
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORTER THIS
CRITICAL BILL THANK YOU. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAD NO OTHER
CALLERS IN THE QUEUE. K.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU TRY THAT ONE
MORE TIME AND ASK FOR OTHERS
WHO WANTED TO COMMENT. ESMA'S
AND GENOMMEN AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT ON AB EIGHT THIRTY
TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN WHY NOT BEEN ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT. AND AT THIS
TIME WE SHOW NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE THE LINES. AND I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE
DRESS. I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TRUE FOR HIS COMMITMENT
ON THIS ISSUE IT'S BEEN A LONG
BATTLE AND THE FACT THAT BOTH
OF CA NOW THE REAL LEAGUE IS A
RURAL LEAGUE ARE AT THIS POINT
ASKING AND TO QUOTE IT'S
CRITICAL TO GET THIS MEASURE TO
THE GOVERNOR FOR SIGNATURE FROM
CA AND FROM THE RURAL LEAGUE WE
MUST MOVE THIS FORWARD I THINK
EVERYBODY RECOGNIZES THAT JUNE
THIRTIETH IS UPON US. AND WE DO
HAVE THE FUNDING AND THIS
MEASURE IS GOING TO FINALLY.
YOU CAN INCREASE THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PAYMENTS. TO MAKE
THE LANDLORD TOLD IT 1100% AND
HELP THE RENTERS AND SO I
CONGRATULATE YOU ON ON PUTTING
THIS BEFORE US THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- TO
OUR HOUSING CHAIR- ALSO WANT TO
EXTEND MY GRATITUDE AND HOW
MUCH WORK THAT YOU'VE PUT INTO
THIS I ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR
LEADERSHIP INCLUDING OUR
MAJORITY LEADER IN OUR SPEAKER-
THE YOU KNOW BEING IN WELL
MATTER WHERE YOU ARE IN
CALIFORNIA FRANKLY BUT NO STATE
STREET SPECIFICALLY TO SAN
JOSE- THERE WAS GREAT FEAR OF
THE LAST FEW DAYS AND WEEKS.
LEADING UP TO THE THIRTIETH AND
I KNOW SAN JOSE AT LEAST WENT
FOR WAS WITH WITH ACTION IS A
CITY BY THE END OF THE DAY AS A
STATE WE JUST WE NEEDED TO ACT
UP AND IT'S NOT ABOUT CREATING
THE PERFECT IS ABOUT AVOIDING
DISASTER. AND I THINK THAT-
WITH WITH. THIS- WE LEASE OTHER.
THE BILL TO TAKE A DEEP BREATH
AND- SEE WHAT ELSE WE NEED TO
DO OVER THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS
TO MAKE SURE WE CAN CREATE
GREATER STABILITY. BUT BUT
WITHOUT THIS EXTRA TIME- TO
YOUR POINT- ASSEMBLY CHU. I
THINK THAT THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY
A CLIFF THAT WE APPEAR SO WE
ARE SO CLOSE. TO FALLING OVER
SO I'M I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO
YOU. AND YOUR STAFF BY NO
CHRISTMAS AMONG THE TIME INTO
THAT THINK INTO THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. JUST GOT. YEAH
PROBABLY WON'T SURPRISE ANYBODY
THAT HAVE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
VIEW- I THINK YOU KNOW WE KEEP
BEING TOLD THAT WE HAVE TO DO
THIS WE HAVE TO DO THIS ITS
ORIGIN- OTHERWISE EVERYTHING'S
GONNA COLLAPSE AND IT IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS
THAT'S ACTUALLY HASN'T BEEN THE
CASE. I MEAN THE DATA THAT WE
HAVE IN FRONT OF US SHOWS
THAT'S NOT THE CASE EARLIER
THIS YEAR. WHEN WE DID THE
EXTENSION. SAYING THINGS ARE
BEING SAID. WE CREATE THIS
PROGRAM AND ALLOCATE- ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS- THIS
SUPPOSED TO BE OUT THERE TO
HELP PEOPLE AND WHAT WE GET
SIXTY ONE POINT SIX MILLION.
THIS BEEN DISTRIBUTED
500-040-0402 APPLICANTS TOTAL-
HERE IS NOT JUST. JAMES
GALLAGHER A REPUBLICAN
LEGISLATOR THE SAID THIS CENTER
SCOTT WIENER SAID THIS- AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR WHEN HE
SAID. LOOK I'M REALLY CONCERNED
QUOTE I AM ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
ADMINISTRATIVE ROLE OUT OF RENT
RELIEF GIVEN THE CALIFORNIA'S
LOGISTICAL PROBLEMS. DURING THE
PANDEMIC. COURSES SEEMS LIKE
THAT. HAS KIND OF APPEARED TO
BE THE CASE ONCE AGAIN- SO YEAH
I MEAN IT IT'S EITHER ONE OF
TWO THINGS AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT IT'S ALL TOGETHER CLEAR
IT'S EITHER. MISMANAGEMENT AND
GETTING THE MONEY OUT WHICH- I
GUESS THAT COULD BE A PROBLEM
FOR THERE'S REALLY NOT THIS
DEMAND THAT EVERYBODY IS SAYING
BECAUSE IN FACT THERE'S BEEN A
AND I'VE ARGUED FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING THAT THE WAY TO DEAL
WITH THIS WAS TO PROVIDE THE
RELIEF TO THE PEOPLE THAT
NEEDED IT. IN TERMS OF GIVING
THEM SUPPORT. MAKING SURE THAT
OUR EDT ACTUALLY GOT PAYMENTS
OUT TO PEOPLE THATWERE
UNEMPLOYED BECAUSE OF CO THAT
HER FOR WHATEVER REASON. RIGHT
GIVING THEM SUPPORT SO THAT
THEY COULD PAY THE RENT. NOT
SAYING TAKE AWAY THE ABILITY OR
THE OBLIGATION. TO PAY RENT- TO
ME THERE IS SO MUCH SUPPORT
THIS OUT THERE FROM THE FEDERAL
AND STATE LEVEL- THAT IT'S IT
APPEARS TO ME IN APPEARANCE
FROM THE DATA FROM THE AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE ACTUALLY
APPLIED. THE PEOPLE CAN PAY THE
RENT. AND THERE'S ALSO BEEN.
ACCORDING TO C. A. AND OTHERS
DOCUMENTED CASES OF PEOPLE WHO
COULD PAY AND ARE REFUSING TO
PAY. OR THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR THE PROGRAM AND AGAIN THESE
PEOPLE ARE LEFT WITH NOTHING.
AND MY PROBLEM ALSO FROM THE
BEGINNING HAS BEEN. THERE'S NO
ONE HERE REPRESENTING THE SMALL
MOM AND POP LANDLORDS. AND SO I
CONTINUE TO TRY AND SPEAK FOR
THEM BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
LOBBYIST TO SHOW UP AS A YEAH
WE'RE OKAY LET'S JUST KEEP THIS
GOING- BUT MEANWHILE THEY ARE
GETTING SHORT CHANGED. FOR NOW
FIFTEEN MONTHS ON RENT. AND
HAVE NOTHING TO DO ABOUT IT AND
THEN IT AND ACCORDING TO THIS
ONLY FIVE THOUSAND FOREIGN
TWENTY TWO APPLICANTS LESS THAN
5% OF THE MONEY HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE. TO SMALL
MOM AND POP LANDLORDS THIS
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THIS IS SOME
HUGE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM- THAT
IS DESPERATELY HELPING HELPING
PEOPLE INTEREST DESPERATE NEED
AND THAT. YOU KNOW HERE HERE
COMES A CLIFF IF WE DON'T
APPROVE IT THAT JUST DOESN'T
APPEAR TO BE THE CASE. AND I
WON'T EVEN GET INTO HOW WE
STARTED THIS WHOLE THING IT
WASN'T US IT WAS ACTUALLY THE
GOVERNOR BY EXECUTIVE ORDER WHO
CHANGE LANDLORD TENANT LAW
OVERNIGHT. WHICH I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY TIMES I GOT A HARP ON
THAT BUT IT'S A BIG PROBLEM
THAT THE EXECUTIVE IS CHANGING
YOUR LAWS. AND WE HAD NOTHING
TO SAY ABOUT IT- AND THAT IS A
JUDICIAL COUNCIL DECIDED TO SAY
HEY COURTS. NO YOU CAN'T DO
YOUR JOB OF EXECUTING THE LAW.
ALL THESE THINGS ARE
PROBLEMATIC AND AGAIN I JUST
DON'T SEE. THE NEED TO CONTINUE
THIS MORATORIUM. SUPPOSEDLY
CALIFORNIA'S RE OPENED YOU KNOW
IT WE WANT WE WANT US WE SAY
THESE CONFLICTING THINGS
REOPENED OR BACK TO BUSINESS
BUSINESSES OPEN AGAIN PEOPLE
CAN GO BACK TO WORK AGAIN-
WE'RE DOING SO GREAT THE
ECONOMY IS JUST GOING TO GANG
BUSTERS BUT NO WE DESPERATELY
NEED. THIS PROGRAM THAT NOT A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE USING AGAIN
LESS THAN 5% OF THE MONEY BEING
EXPENDED AND I WONDER IF THAT'S
ACTUALLY THE CASE LET'S
ANNOUNCED TWO BILLION MORE
DOLLARS WE'RE GOING TO THROW
OUT THERE. RIGHT NOW I GOT FIVE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS THAT
WERE ALLOCATED TO HELP PEOPLE.
WITH RIGHT RELIEF AND THEN
ACTUALLY NONE OF THAT MONEY
ACTUALLY GETS OUT. TO HELP
PEOPLE RIGHT IT'S SO VERY GAVIN
NEWSOM. ANNOUNCE A BIG PROGRAM
NOTHING GETS REALLY EXECUTED-
BUT WE'RE ALL SUPPOSED TO
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS. YOU KNOW
THIS IS GREAT POLICY IT'S NOT
AND I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
ANYMORE. THIS GONZALEZ. I WANT
TO THANK YOU- FOR WORKING ON
THIS I A I A REPRESENT A- LARGE
QUESTION MY DISTRICT TO RENTERS
I ALSO HAVE A LARGE PORTION OF
A DISTRICT THAT WAS HIGHLY
AFFECTED NOT BY STATE HOME
ORDERS WITH THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE- SERVICE WORKERS IN THE
TOURISM INDUSTRY AND DESPITE
OPENING BACK UP THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THINGS GET BACK TO NORMAL
RIGHT AWAY DOESN'T MEAN
EVERYBODY'S- BEING HIRED BACK.
AND I ALSO HAVE A HIGH NUMBER
OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED AND QUITE FRANKLY-
SOMETIMESHAD TO STOP WORKING
BECAUSE A CO ED- AND WE'RE
STRUGGLING TO PAY THE RENT THIS
IS NOT A PERFECT SOLUTION
EVERYBODY SEEMS A LITTLE HAPPY
IN A LITTLE UPSET THAT PROBABLY
MEANS IT'S THE RIGHT SOLUTION-
AND IT DOES PROVIDE A HUNDRED
PERCENT- RECLAIMING OF AS MANY
FOR THE LANDLORDS AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT AS WELL WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE LOSING- THEIR THEIR
RENTAL PROPERTIES WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE LOSING THEIR HOMES. SO
HAVING GONE OUT WITH MY STAFF
TO HELP PEOPLE FILL OUT THESE
FORMS I CAN TELL YOU THAT IT
WAS A DAUNTING EXPERIENCE
THERE'S A REASON SO LITTLE OF
THIS MONEY HAS GONE OUT IN
ANYONE WHO HAS ACTUALLY GONE
OUT AND TALKED TO CONSTITUENTS
AND HELP THEM FILL OUT FORMS
YOU KNOW FOR HOURS LITERALLY
HOURS TO TRY TO FILL OUT THESE
FORMS AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO
APPLY FOR THE MONEY KNOWS THE
BUREAUCRATIC HURDLES WE'RE
DEALING WITH AND SOME OF IT NOT
BECAUSE OF US BUT BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL. ON SOME
THE RENTAL RELIEF SO- IS A
PERFECT YOU KNOW WILL KEEP
PEOPLE FROM BEING DISPLACED AND
GROWING- NUMBER OF HOMELESS
ABSOLUTELY IT WILL AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO PUT SO MUCH
MONEY INTO ENDING HOMELESSNESS-
THE LAST THING WE WANT IS FOR
MORE FAMILIES BE HOMELESS AND
SO I AT I KNOW THIS WAS NOT
EASY- AND SO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU BECAUSE I KNOW HOW
MUCH TIME AND EFFORT YOU PUT
INTO THIS. AND THE VERY REAL
PROBLEMS THAT SOME OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE FACING. AND
THE VERY REAL DYNAMIC OF NOT
BEING ABLE TO PAY BACK RENT AND
KNOWING. WHEN THE MORATORIUM
ENDS THEY'RE GOING TO BE
AFFECTED- THIS HOPEFULLY WILL
RELIEVE THEM OF THAT PRESSURE
AND LET PEOPLE STARTED NEIL IN
SO. THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS
AND- ASSUME IT'S BEEN MOVED
BECAUSE IT HAS NOT YET I'D BE
HAPPY TO WITH THE BILL. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. RIGHT THE WITH THE
MESSAGE TO YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU LET ME UP FOR START BY- BY
THANKING- THE CHAIR AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY COMMITTEE AND IN PARTICULAR
FOR WORKING WITH LEADERSHIP
LEADERSHIP STAFF I WANT TO
THANK THE MAJORITY LEADER- THIS
WAS SOMETHING THAT CAME
TOGETHER VERY QUICKLY- IN
ENGAGEMENT WITH. OUR FELLOW
SENATORS AND OUR GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND UST APPRECIATE HOW
MUCH WORK HAS GONE INTO THIS IN
THE LAST FEW WEEKS I DO WANNA
RESPOND TO A COUPLE OF POINTS
THAT WERE RAISED ACROSS THE
AISLE IT IS TRUE THAT WE HAVE
NOT SEEN. THE WAVE OF ACTIONS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORRIED ABOUT
AND THAT IS BECAUSE WE HAVE PUT
THESE PROTECTIONS AND THAT IS
BECAUSE WHEN THE COURT-
MORATORIUM ENDED LAST SUMMER WE
MOVE FORTY B. THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT IT IS BECAUSE- AND- I
THINK BEFORE OUR CALL THE CAME
INTO THIS COMMITTEE HEARING I'D
MENTION A COUPLE THE STATISTICS
THAT JUST THIS MONTH ONE POINT
SEVEN FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSEHOLDS REPORTED TO
THE CENSUS. SLIDER NO
CONFIDENCE IN THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY THE NEXT MONTH'S RENT THE
RECENT POLICY LIKE ANALYSIS
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE BEHIND ON
THEIR RENT AND THEIR STATISTICS
ON HOW FAR THEY ARE BEHIND ON
THE RENT WE KNOW THAT WHILE NOT
EVERYONE IS STRUGGLING AT THIS
MOMENT WE STILL HAVE MANY
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE BEHIND-
AND LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT MONIES HAVING GONE OUT
FIRST OF ALL. IT IS TRUE A VERY
SMALL FRACTION OF CHECKS HAVE
ACTUALLY GOTTEN IN THE HANDS OF
STRUGGLING TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS BUT MANY FOLKS OF
APPLIED THEIR APPLICATIONS ARE
LITERALLY PENDING AND SO THE
IDEA THAT SOMEHOW WE WOULD
ALLOW THE ACTIONS TO START AND
THREE DAYS WHILE FOLKS ARE
WAITING TO SEE WHETHER THEIR
APPLICATIONS WILL BE APPROVED I
THINK WOULD BE CHALLENGING- I
WANT TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN ASKED A LOT
WHY THE DISBURSEMENT HAS BEEN
SO CHALLENGING. IT'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF REASONS- FIRST OF ALL
THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM IT WAS
JUST SET UP A FEW MONTHS AGO WE
ALL KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
SET UP NEW PROGRAMS
PARTICULARLY PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
CONFLICTING AND SHIFTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE COMING
DOWN FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FROM THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND FOR MANY
JURISDICTIONS AROUND CALIFORNIA
SO FEDERAL STATE LOCAL
PROVISIONS. THERE HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGES WHEN IT COMES TO
EDUCATING MILLIONS OF TENANTS
AND LANDLORDS CHALLENGES AROUND
LANGUAGE ACCESS CHALLENGES
AROUND THE DIGITAL DIVIDE- AND
CHALLENGES FRANKLY IN THE
COMPLICATED APPLICATION THAT
HAS JUST BEEN STREAMLINED AGAIN
THIS PAST MONTH SO THESE ARE
ALL THINGS THAT HAVE LED TO
WHERE WE ARE TODAY BUT THE FACT
OF THE MATTER IS WE'RE SITTING
ON OVER FOUR BILLION DOLLARS OF
RENTAL ASSISTANCE. THAT COULD
GO TO FOLKS WERE STRUGGLING AND
AGAIN THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD
TURN ON THE FICTION SPIGOT IN
THREE DAYS- WHEN WE COULD HELP
THESE FOLKS IS NOT ONE THAT I
THINK MAKES SENSE- I KNOW OUR
COLLEAGUES. ACROSS THE AISLE
TALKED ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON PROVIDING RELIEF FOR
THOSE WHO NEED IT AND- THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT. THIS BILL
ENVISIONS THIS BILL ENVISIONS
THAT POTENTIALLY IN THREE
MONTHS ON SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH.
EVICTIONS WILL BEGIN AGAIN. AND
WHAT IT ALSO SAYS IS THERE ARE
PROTECTIONS. FOR TENANTS WHO
HAVEN'T GOTTEN THE FINANCIAL
SYSTEMS THAT THEY MIGHT.
REQUIRE THEIR PROTECTIONS WHEN
OF ACTION START TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT AND THAT IS- WERE
REALLY LITERALLY TRYING TO
ENVISION WHAT- WHAT WAS
SUGGESTED AND HOW WE SHOULD
STRUCTURE THIS. I KNOW TERE'S
ALSO BEEN SOME SUGGESTION THAT
THERE ARE TENANTS OUT THERE
WHO- COULD AFFORD TO PAY- BUT
IF NOT IN A FEW THINGS I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO MENTION. IS AT
THIS MOMENT IF A TENANT- IF THE
TENANT SIGNS. A DOCUMENT SAYING%
THAT THEY'VE EXPERIENCED A
COVERED HARDSHIP- THEY'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE EVICTED. THEY
SIGNED UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY. WHICH MEANS THAT THEY
COULD BE PROSECUTED FOR FRAUD
IF THEY'RE RELYING. THIS BILL
AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO ALSO
ENVISIONS THAT THERE MIGHT BE
TENANTS WHO LEAVE THEIR HOMES
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T PAY AND IF
THAT HAPPENS. LANDLORDS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO APPLY FOR
FUNDING AND RECEIVE THAT FUNNY
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT.
ADVOCATES FOR LANDLORDS VERY
MUCH WANTED AS PART OF THIS.
ALSO MENTION IF IT TURNS OUT.
THAT A TENANT IS ABLE TO PAY.
OUR WE HAVE MADE IT EASIER
THROUGH THE BILLS THAT WE'VE
PASSED TO ALLOW LANDLORDS TO
BRING. A SMALL CLAIMS ACTIONS
WHICH ARE CHEAPER WHICH DON'T
REALLY REQUIRE- YOU TO LAWYER
UP. IN ORDER TO- TO- MAKE SURE
THAT YOU RECEIVE THE UNPAID
RENT AT- AND IF FULLER GETS A
MONEY JUDGMENT. A TENANTS WAGES
CAN BE GARNISHED FUNDS CAN BE
WITHDRAWN FROM THEIR BANK
ACCOUNTS AGAIN TO ENSURE THAT.
WITH THE INSTANCE OF FOLKS WHO-
WHO ARE NOT OF THE LOWER INCOME
BRACKETS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- THAT THERE IS- THERE IS
RECOURSE THERE BUT I WOULD JUST
SUGGEST THAT ALL THE DATA
SHOWS. THAT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF TENANTS WHO ARE
INSIGNIFICANT RENTALS AT THIS
POINT. MAKE BELOW 80% OF THE
AREA MEDIAN INCOME WHICH WOULD
MEAN THAT THERE WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FUNDING THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT- LET ME JUST
END- WITH OUR STARTED WHICH IS.
WHICH IS TO SAY. AT THIS VERY
MOMENT WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS THAT
ARE. BEHIND ON THEIR RENT THE
IDEA THAT SOMEHOW WE WOULD TURN
ON ADDICTIONS WHEN WE'VE GOT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO BE ABLE
TO SYSTEM. WE WOULD SERIOUSLY
UNDERMINE THEIR CHANCES OF US
BEING ABLE TO HELP GETTING THEM
BACK ON THEIR FEET AND SO WITH
THAT COLLEAGUES AGAIN. REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE ENGAGEMENT
ON THIS THERE BEEN MANY ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS- IN RECENT WEEKS
ON EXACTLY WHAT TO DO HERE-
THIS MAY NOT BE PERFECT BUT IT
REPRESENTS THAT BALANCE OF WHAT
WE NEED TO DO TO MOVE THINGS
FORWARD. GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW AT
THIS TIME AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER TO ON AB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. THAT MOTION IS
DUE PASSED WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE FLOOR
AMENDMENTS. ADOPTED CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NOTE
SHALL. SHALL I CHOOSE HI CHIU
AYE DAVIES. DAVIES NOW
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES. YES I. THANK YOU THE
BILL WAS OUT. CAN I WILL CALL
THE ROLL OPEN FOR A FEW MINUTES
FOR MR HOLDEN IF HE WANTS TO
COME AND VOTE COULD BE
CONTACTED OFFICE PLEASE. SO.
EXTRATORRENT.
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI
RIGHT THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES
OUR BUSINESS FOR TODAY AND WE
ARE CONCERNED. THANKS GUYS.